غلاف غزه للتو اذا يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان خمسه ضباط وجنود اصيبوا في معار قطاع
غزه خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه بالفعل وهذا عثمان يشي بان
المعارك ما زالت مستمره وما زالت على
اشدها وفي الدقائق الاخيره شهدت الاجواء
تحليقا كثيفا للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي
الذي اغار على مناطق بعينها في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه على نحو ال الخصوص
وكانت هذه الغارات قريبه جدا من السياج
الامني هذه المناطق التي يستهدفها الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالمدفعيه وبالطيب الحربي
وبالتفكير على اعتبار انه يريد تدمير هذه
المنازل القريبه من السياج الامني في اطار
رؤيته لاقامه المنطقه العازله والعمق
الاستراتيجي والامني الذي يريد ان يحيط به
منطقه غلاف غزه وهذه الغارات تاتي في وقت
نشرت فيه القناه الثانيه
الاسرائيليه دراسه اعدتها الجامعه العبريه
بمدينه القدس والتي اشارت الى ان نحو
75000 مبنى في قطاع غزه عموما قد تضررت
بفعل هذه الحرب وقد اشارت الى ان
42% من مباني قطاع غزه عموما تضررت جراء
القصف الجوي والمدفعي والعمليات العسكريه
الضمار الاكبر حل في مدينه غزه ونحن عثمان
نرى هذه المناطق الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه
غزه وبالفعل هو ضمار كبير جدا تشير
الدراسه الى ان الدمار الاكبر حقيقه وقع
في مدينه غزه حيث ان
55% من مباني ال المدينه قد تضررت ربما
تكون تضررت بشكل شبه كامل مسحت عن الارض
او تضررت بشكل جزئي لكن الدمار الكبير حل
في هذه المدينه فيما تشير الدراسه الى ان
44% من بباني شمال القطاع قد قد تضررت في
منطقه خانيونس الاشاره الى ان هنالك 40%
من المباني قد تضررت و 30% في المخيمات
الوسطى في حين ان 20% من المباني عثمان قد
تضررت في مدينه رفح التي لم تصلها المعارك
والمعارك الكبرى حتى الان لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يدخل الى تلك المناطق بعد
وهو ما زال ربما ينتظر قرارا سياسيا بهذا
ال الخصوص على ايه حال الصوره هنا من
عندنا في منطقه الغلاف تشي بهذه الارقام
وتؤكد الدمار الكبير الذي كنا قد تحدثنا
عنه انا انوه الى الخبر العاجل الاخر نقلا
عن الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يقول ان هناك
356 ضابطا وجنديا ما زالوا يتلقون العلاج
اثر اصابتهم في معارك غزه 25 منهم جروحهم
خطيره
نعم بالفعل عثمان وهذا هو التحديث الاخير
للجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يشير في تقريره
اليوم الى ان عدد الجنود والضباط الذين
جرحوا منذ بدايه الحرب في السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي بلغ
2825 جنديا وضابطا ومنذ بدايه العمليات
العسكريه بلغ العدد
1302 لكن هذه الارقام تبقى عثمان مخالفه
لكثير من التقارير الصحفيه التي كانت
تتحدث عن اعداد اكبر بكثير باتت تفوق ال
5000 وما يزيد وهي تختلف كذلك عن الارقام
التي نشرتها المستشفيات والقوائم المتوفره
بهذا الخصوص لكن هذه الارقام تب تبقى
الارقام الرسميه التي يعلن عنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي اشار ايضا الى اصابه خمسه
من جنوده وضباطه في معارك الساعات ال 24
المم ja